foreign
hey everybody what's going on what's up
it's Monday slasher friend said what
movie were you going to review yesterday
we didn't have one to review yesterday
because
um
we didn't watch a movie Saturday did we
we watched uh I think we watched Cobra
Kai
and watch the first episode yeah we
watched Cobra Kai
next adventure media said Jenny did you
make it to Disney this weekend if so
hope you had a great time yes I did I
went yesterday and I had a blast when me
and my sister went and she that's what
she bought me for my uh for my birthday
she got me a ticket for the Halloween
party at uh Disney and it was super
super fun we had such a good time I
didn't get home until almost two o'clock
in the morning
so but yeah it was like really fun I
still knocked that [ __ ] down when she
came in though I know because I was like
really I'm sure yeah I didn't let her
get away or not I seriously I think I
got maybe three hours of sleep yeah no
because I wake up super super early I
woke up in a minute
I woke up and saw that [ __ ] and I was
gonna I'm gonna get somewhere okay it
was like at this point it was like 2 30
in the morning yeah and I was sitting
there going oh my God I'm so tired I've
been like walking around Disney like all
day I couldn't resist I couldn't resist
that [ __ ]
said I saw a smile over the weekend yeah
I've I've been hearing like different
things about that and I kind of want to
see it like the trailer looked really
good
but yeah see look I got um I got a
Madame Leota t-shirt from The Haunted
Mansion I haven't seen it yeah I think
it's got medicine yeah yeah it looks
good because I went in the the shop that
they have there by the Haunted Mansion
which is called Mori
man we ought to [ __ ] make a rip off
yeah we can't call it Madame Leona no
not because that's like there's nothing
else yeah there's other characters in
that kind of [ __ ] or something kind of
like it yeah they had a bunch of cool
[ __ ] in that store though I was like
well I told my sister I was like well I
told myself I wasn't gonna spend a
million dollars in here but I said I
kind of wanted a new wallet because my
uh while it's getting really old and
flaking off and it's kind of too big for
my purse so I said oh maybe they have
like kind of a cool Haunted Mansion one
but they didn't have anything like that
but of course as soon as I went in there
I saw like 50 bajillion other things I
wanted like but I was able to restrain
myself and just buy the T-shirt but you
know what I mean uh let's see
um Zach says Jenny you guys have to
watch Blonde by the way it is pretty
much a horror movie that's the one yeah
yeah I've been wanting to see that
actually that's one with anadarmus about
um Marilyn Monroe and I heard it was
like really surrealist and pretty fun
uh and Castle or Garcia says [ __ ] is a
good horror flick that's on shutter
right I think I just saw that come up
today so yeah well we have to pick
something to watch tonight so we'll find
something I don't know like I said it
can't be anything too complicated
because I'm like really really tired
yeah because like I walked we haven't
had a lot of sleep lately yeah I mean
warm and everything yeah like I said I
think I maybe slept three hours last
night well that's probably my fault too
because I was trying to like stay up
because the Halloween party at Disney
like went until midnight and actually
was longer than that because they did a
stage show at midnight so we stayed and
watched that and then like you know you
have to wait for the monorail and then
you have to then it was like a 50 minute
drive home so I didn't get home until
almost two and then I woke up at like
seven this new protocol I'm on it really
[ __ ] your sleep up yeah and
I hadn't had any major [ __ ] Behavior
disturbances
but it it gives you insomnia
yeah
yeah
I mean you can't get any more in about
three three hours of consecutive sleep
well like I said that's kind of that's
kind of what I've been having too right
but yeah so I mean we knew that we had
to do
The Haunting thing because everybody
loves these so we actually watched it we
watched a couple episodes on Saturday
night because we couldn't decide which
one we wanted to do
and then I was like I was kind of
re-watching a couple of them today and I
was like the first one that we watched I
think we were gonna go with that one
because the one we're gonna do today is
monster in the apartment I think the one
we watched after that was the possessed
which was okay but I don't know I didn't
I didn't love it as much as I don't know
I thought this one was kind of like
cooler although I will say that the the
episode the possessed I can't remember
it's probably season four
um it did have one of the creepiest
uh things in it where like the mom or
whatever like gets possessed and she's
driving her kids and she's just like
staring at the kid like the whole time
while she's driving it's like ooh that
was like really creepy like the look on
her face is like around talking to that
one it's just yeah kind of lower on the
on the totem pole than this one I'd
rather talk about this one even though
this one has some
this one kind of has I would say kind of
filler in it but well they all do they
all do they all do though right and
there was a little bit I didn't find
someone backstory on this particular
case but
um the woman that's on this that was
telling the story like the main woman uh
turns out she was and I don't know I'm
not gonna go so far to say it was maybe
it was like a little bit disingenuous
but because I think she kind of
persuades herself as like a skeptic at
first but she's actually like a pretty
well-known like Paranormal
investigator type person yeah and she's
not connected with the war and so the
other one I think was wouldn't it no
this one had a little bit of Warren Zone
it's a little sprinkling of Warrens no
but just Lorraine though I think this
took place after Ed Warren died you know
what I mean
uh Zach said I remember the bit from
this episode with the door slamming
while her in the wheelchair-bound girl
are sleeping yeah yeah yeah that was
good yeah I actually did really like
that scene and that woman couldn't turn
over to see yeah because she was like
but yeah that's the thing and it's like
that actress because I immediately
recognized that same actress that plays
like the um the paraplegic girl in this
one is the same actress that was in that
other episode which I think is called
hidden Terror that's about that guy and
his girlfriend that move into that house
and then she gets like all depressed
like because the house like makes
everybody like feel super super
depressed or just women it seems like
because he didn't seem to feel like that
his big thing was like he would just
come home and like the mail was all over
them you can't have visions of that
pyramid and the ghosts around it and
remember that was that that episode I
think the same one you're talking about
yeah no I think that's it I think that's
the difference no no no no that was the
other one see we're getting them all
we're getting confused well that's the
thing and plus sometimes like if we
watch one we'll watch like a whole bunch
of them so sometimes
so that's why like usually for the show
I'll usually watch the episode twice
just not sure that I'm not confusing the
details with another one because
sometimes we'll watch two or three of
them in one night so I actually watched
this one Saturday night and then I
watched it again like a couple of hours
ago and like made notes about it so
there's that
um let's see let's do we have anything
else we need to address before
yeah Zach says oh yeah hidden Tara
that's the one with that dude Johnny
Alonzo in it I talked to him on
Instagram before he's super cool oh okay
hidden Terror yeah maybe we'll do that
one that's that's the one with the yeah
where the woman is seeing the the
triangle with the Ghosts no it's just I
don't think she's seeing that is she
dreaming it or she's having visions of
it or something all I remember is they
move into the house and she's really
really sad and like she's in one she's
an artist but I didn't even know she
could she was painting like I thought
she was like not couldn't paint anything
because she was just like depressed all
the time yeah no she she started
painting that and they showed the actual
painting
mango said uh also saw a smile tonight
and was very good yeah that it looks
good like I saw the trailer and it
looked really good so I definitely do
kind of want to see that eventually
whether we'll go to the theater and see
it I'm not really sure
um you know we might end up waiting for
it to come out on streaming because that
seems like what we're doing because the
you know the movie theater we're still
paying for that [ __ ] but it's like we
never make it down it's just far it's
kind of far
I mean it was slightly far before but
now it's like really far it's like a
whole day it's like a whole day
Endeavor you know what I mean and it's
been kind of like uh
we never even got to see Top Gun at it
or anything
maybe we should kill our subscriptions I
don't know but it's good to have it
every now and then because special
events and
you know although you can buy those
separate anyway the special events
that's what I'm saying anything that's
fathom events is gonna be right uh is
gonna be like extra because like riff
tracks live you just you have to pay for
that we just have to go twice a month to
make it work that's what I'm saying
which isn't that bad yeah really we just
need to start going twice a month yeah
we probably should I mean they have to
start going back there's [ __ ] that I
want to see it's just that we just never
end up going
if we go we got to go during the day
yeah that's when it makes the most sense
when it's dead
we can just drive down there yeah see it
and then come back because it's a lot
the traffic and everything you know it's
a lot easier I hate fighting those
nighttime crowds
yeah uh well Lily said did you see
amulet Jenny yes I did um I remember
liking it but I don't really remember
like all that much about it because it
was a while back that I saw it
and let's see oh okay and zax is another
thing to sweeten the deal for blonde
which is like a Marilyn Monroe movie
Warren Ellison Nick Cave composed the
score and it's so good yeah so now I'm
definitely gonna have to see it I've
been wanting to see it anyway because it
looked really good and like I said I
really like Anna Martin and I've been
seeing like the stills from it it looks
really cool
so are you ready to start talking about
the episode yeah
and I mean if at the end like if anybody
like wants me to talk about like being
at the Disney party thing then I'll talk
about that but let's talk about the
episode first
well that too we're gonna run off and go
and wake somebody you can talk about you
could run up yeah
we're gonna run out of time
yeah well you know
food going up in this [ __ ] only
been on for 15 minutes
you know we get off at [ __ ] 10
o'clock and you know there's no time
it's not gonna be 10 o'clock we're not
gonna be now you're trying to watch
movies or do it or cook so you just
going better hungry
it's only six o'clock okay and these
aren't and this isn't like a Sidetrack
show okay so it's we're just a haunting
show all right so these usually just run
like hour half two hours something like
that which is totally acceptable yeah
because like I said we need time to like
watch a movie tonight too because we got
a movie to talk about tomorrow
so all right so this episode uh was
actually season four episode 12 as I
mentioned called monster in the
apartment uh first aired I believe in
November of 2007.
so this episode actually starts with a
little bit of a prologue kind of thing
and you don't really find out what's
going on with it or who the [ __ ] this is
or what's the deal until later on in the
show
so the first thing they should they just
dive right into it because you know how
most of the episodes they start out with
you know here's so and so in the city
and it's this year and bloody blah they
didn't really do that on this one it was
like a little bit I mean they did but
they did like the prologue first so in
the prologue there's this little girl
and she's sleeping in her bed and she
hears like a creaking sound I guess like
somebody walking around on the hall or
whatever and and it just kind of sounds
like somebody's out there like
scratching so she goes out in the
hallway to see what it is which again if
you're a little kid why would you do
that I think I would just like hide
under the bed or whatever but okay
so she goes out into the hallway
and at the end of the hall there's like
a closed door I don't know what room
it's supposed to be and she can see all
this really bright like shifting white
light underneath it and so she starts
walking toward it for some reason like I
said why would you do that I don't know
um and she keeps hearing these weird
sounds and then all of a sudden the door
pops open and there's really bright blue
white kind of light in there and wind
blowing and [ __ ] like that and it's kind
of they kind of make with the camera
tracking like it's coming at her you
know what I mean like here it is so she
screams then we Fade to Black and then
we jump to the main story which takes
place 10 years after that because it
just says 10 years later you know what I
mean so it's almost like a little bit of
a cold open but they don't even tell you
like what any of that is or what it
means in our normal experience when she
was a kid
yeah that's but like you don't find that
out until later like you don't find out
what the what the connection is
so this story actually takes place in
Edmonton Canada in February of 2003.
so we're following uh a woman named
Morgan nudson nudson
Newton Knudsen I think he said it with a
K like and I was like is that really how
this I mean she was on there so I guess
that's how you pronounce her last name
but I would say that think that K was
silent but it's Canada it's not my name
so how the hell is it
it's Knudsen yeah from Canuck land yeah
but uh so yeah
so she's like a musician and a composer
seems like she doesn't really have all
that much money and she said that her
parents had divorced and had moved out
of the province and so she doesn't
really have anywhere to go so she's kind
of been like couch surfing at her
friend's houses and [ __ ] like that she
said she was getting kind of bummed out
about it because she wanted to stay in
Edmonton so uh she finds a job at like a
computer tech support center like to
make ends meet but obviously that's not
enough rent like that's not enough to
pay rent on an apartment like on your
own
so she has this co-worker and his name
is Bob I think they said levec I'm not
really sure what the spelling is on that
I spelled it l-e-v-e-q-u-e because
Canada and French and everything and I
just assumed but I don't but I don't
know like I said it might be Jewish well
no I mean the way they said it it just
kind of sounded like I was like that
sounds like a French last name okay
and so I just assumed but I don't really
know because he wasn't on there so we
don't even know we don't know what
happened to Bob I don't even know if
that's his real name or not so there's
that uh so he's they work together now
he also needs a place to live because he
just got divorced like his wife just
left him and like took their two sons
and like moved away and he's kind of in
a bad place so he needs a place to live
too so the two of them are friends and
they decide to become roomies so they
find this really nice apartment uh it's
on the fourth floor but there's no
elevator so it must be like an old
building it's just like a walk up you
know what I mean uh so yeah
um and basically like Morgan is on there
and she says uh you know he's a very
friendly person and he's very outgoing
and stuff but he was kind of having a
hard time because he hadn't seen his
kids in a long time and he really missed
them and blah blah and he was going
through some [ __ ]
um now she also finds out when they move
in together that he's uh Wiccan because
he puts up all the candles and all that
whatnot and she's like going to be like
witchcraft he's like that's a common
misconception I thought that was funny
like the way he said that but you know
what I mean he was like he gets all
[ __ ] he gets all he gets all well
actually about it that's what I'm saying
there's a lot of well actuallying dudes
in this one I'm just and we'll get to
there's another one too that's even
worse but yeah so he's like you know
telling her like all the candles and how
they represent different stuff and she's
just basically like well I'm agnostic I
don't give a [ __ ] what you do just you
know don't burn the chat jump burn the
house down uh so a couple days later
this is kind of the first thing and like
I said I don't know if this is
Paranormal but this is the first thing
that they said that they noticed okay so
the few days after they move in they
come back from grocery shopping and they
find that they can't get into the
apartment like neither of their sets of
keys will work in the lock Morgan said
it felt like somebody was on the other
side of the door like preventing the key
from turning in the lock they said
almost like someone was like holding oh
my God or something like that she said
that's what it felt like and then then
she said they hear these kind of weird
furtive like shuffling noises and like
footsteps from inside the apartment that
makes them think obviously that
somebody's in there that like somebody
broke in they didn't think it was ghosts
or nothing they just obviously thought
somebody had broken in so Morgan goes
outside and like looks up at the windows
of their apartment which I guess like
all the curtains were open and [ __ ] like
that and she's like I didn't see anybody
in there like I didn't see any Shadows
moving around or anything like that
which apparently you would have been
able to see
um so now the program like on the show
they do actually show there's like a
little ghost boy like up there in the
window going hey what's going on but
like you know obviously she didn't say
she said that she saw that she said that
she didn't see anybody that's just the
haunting being a haunted being a haunted
yeah it's just like hey I'm here even
though she can't see me you know what I
mean yeah he was like that
so she comes back up
but now the door to the apartment is
open and like all the groceries are
still sitting there like in front of the
thing and she's like what the [ __ ] and
she's like calling Bob and then he pops
in and does like a jump scare and he's
like oh my key works all of a sudden I'm
like why do you take the groceries in
[ __ ] what are you doing so and
then like just popped out and scared her
Zach's talking about my beard oh
somebody noticed it finally he wanted to
see how long it was how long it took
before somebody noticed it it's just
been going on for a couple of episodes
it's just that you guys didn't notice it
couldn't really see it that much well on
the Friday night show like I didn't I
couldn't even really see it we're gonna
see if I'll have the sides or if I'm
just gonna do do an evil Spock I'm gonna
do one of the one or the other we'll see
how it goes I'm gonna [ __ ] I like it
though I do too
I wasn't sure I would but now that I see
it I like it it did this you know most
people seem to like the the side part
too but I could just do the biker thing
you know I don't know I kind of like the
side thing okay we'll see we'll see it's
gonna be Dan either way yeah that's all
right then sharp looking
manga said the audition for The Village
People went well then
yeah you talk about me yeah are you fine
is it fun to stay at the YMCA
[Laughter]
Blueprints and [ __ ]
foreign
all right
well that man all man love
he's young man
young man they got nowhere to go
they're up in there in that YMCA
inside him saunas
Zach says if all else fails he could do
a Vincent Price stash for Halloween
that would be a cool actually that would
be a cool uh Halloween costume would be
like doing a Vincent Price character
from one of his movies like one of the
Edgar Allan Poe movies or something yeah
I don't know what he looked like
you know what Vincent Price looks like
yeah but I don't know what his mustache
look like well yeah okay
he had a guy I think I don't I don't
like I don't I'm not gonna do just a
mustache it has to be a [ __ ] full
facial hair apparatus
it's a facial hair apparatus
yeah you scared me like a really funny
mental image of like a bunch of like
gears yeah bullies and stuff like that
yeah it's an apparatus it's just got to
be [ __ ] Macho
of course it does yeah of course it does
Toby's gonna love that [ __ ] Toby's got
just the evil Spock [ __ ] mustache
yeah yeah
yeah you're gonna have to do like beard
apparatus comparisons yeah like next
time we see it yeah I'm gonna you can
try to out leather daddy that leather
oh boy Erica yeah macho man I went to
the [ __ ] biker bar with that you know
but it was it was still [ __ ] white
because it's mostly white I [ __ ]
touched it up a little bit of dye that
just for men and that that helped make
it pop a little bit because you couldn't
see it on camera before but you can see
it
you can see it on me but it was [ __ ]
white
I went to the [ __ ] biker bar like
that they like that [ __ ] they like they
said no no I just leave it just leave it
white like that
yeah that's how they are yeah so you
don't think I should do a [ __ ] get it
black again and just leave it white
yeah yeah the girl the [ __ ]
um uh Amy was like no make it back
the girls were like make it back I call
them the girls they're women you know
50s make it back
Paint It Black yeah your face looks like
[ __ ]
that's [ __ ] hilarious yeah yeah yeah
yeah
they're funny man
body looks great your face looks like
[ __ ]
you're a butterface yeah is that what
they were trying to tell you no she said
your eyes are all black you're like a
raccoon when's the last time you slept
yeah and it was up oh I think I just saw
an orb oh really like go behind there
yeah that's my spiritual energy I guess
so right
swampcast
Danny Rowling said uh The People Under
the Stairs which I just got on DVD great
original film would make a good review
I'm pretty sure we've reviewed The
People Under the Stairs it was probably
a while back as that Wes Craven movie
yeah we've done it yeah I'm sure we've
done it
Zach says also what is it with
everyone's Uncle having a mustache at
some point
I don't know I don't know
um yeah so where was I okay so uh so Bob
got into the apartment uh you know the
key worked all of a sudden and then
they're like oh well maybe the sounds
just came from the adjoining apartment
even though they're pretty sure that the
apartment next door is vacant like
nobody lives in there
so later that night Morgan hears
creaking noises like somebody's like
walking around now obviously she thinks
it's Bob like you would like maybe he
got up to go to the bathroom or is going
to get a drink or some [ __ ] like that
she gets out of bed and goes down the
hall to Bob's room and
um so the show like I said I always try
to like point out the distinction
between what the actual people said and
what they actually showed in the
reenactment like I said it could be that
they said that in the interview and then
they just didn't show them saying it in
the interview but then they just
reenacted it I don't know because I
wasn't there but uh the show actually
like demonstrates that she heard
something that kind of sounded like a
sighing type noise and then it shows
like Ghost Boy again like behind her but
of course she you know didn't say that
she saw that
um and I don't actually know if she
heard anything like that PSY noise
although I think she said later that she
did hear some stuff like that so she
kind of pops into Bob's room and Bob is
asleep but of course you know he wakes
up when she like pops in and is like
what the [ __ ] are you walking around and
he's like no I'm not walking around
um you know it says don't worry about
the noises it's just an old building
blah blah so she's like whatever she
goes back to back to bed says the whole
experience was what she called unnerving
that was the word that she used like the
real lady
foreign
so Bob then we show Bob like in his bed
and behind him there's that bright blue
white light again like we saw the little
girl seeing at the beginning right and
some wind blowing and all that kind of
action
um and it seems to be approaching him so
he sits up and sees Ghost Boy Who Says
something like I think it sounded like
I'm lonely is that what he said like I
was trying to like that's what it
sounded like to me and for some reason
like when I watched these on my Mac
normally I would put the um closed
captioning on but for some reason I
can't get this captioning to come on on
my on my Mac when I watch it on there I
don't know why
um so I think that's what he said I
think the boy said I'm lonely
now uh like I said keep in mind that Bob
was not interviewed on the show we don't
know where he is now uh or or anything
so who knows like if that really
happened or not I'm assuming that
they're going by what Morgan said that
Bob had told her that's that's what I'm
assuming
so two weeks after they move into this
apartment
Bob and Morgan have a little
housewarming get-together and they
invite two of their friends now one of
these friends as I mentioned earlier is
played by the same actress who was in
Hidden Terror
um so this friend is a grad student
whose name is I think her name's
Stephanie but I think they said her last
name was words I that's kind of what I
heard like I said I could didn't have
the closed captioning on
um and she was interviewed on the show
like a little bit I think they only had
like two or three clips of her but she
was on there as well
uh so she's making jokes because she's
like I said she's in a wheelchair she's
paraplegic and she's like why you
[ __ ] have to like move into a you
know apartment and a walk up like you
don't even have an elevator and like so
somebody every time she comes over
somebody has to like essentially like
carry her in her wheelchair like up the
stairs you know what I mean uh because
that's the only way that she can uh get
up there which has got to be a giant
pain in the ass
so Morgan and Stephanie have apparently
been best friends since high school
so the other friend that's invited is
named Court uh which I'm assuming is
short for Courtney and he's the manager
of the tech center where Morgan and Bob
both work so they've I'm not sure how
well they knew him prior to this but
yeah they invited him over
so they're all talking around the table
having some wine or whatever and Morgan
makes a joke about Bob sneaking out at
night like to see a girl hey who you
sneaking out and I just see because she
keeps hearing the creaking and thinks
that it's Bob like sneaking out the
apartment at night now he kind of gets
uncomfortable like [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
are you talking about like I don't you
know but he just kind of tries to play
it off because he doesn't want to make a
scene I guess but like after the end of
the party he asked her is like were you
really serious about hearing footsteps
because uh because it's not me
and she's like well maybe I'm just
imagining it maybe it's just the house
settling or whatever and he's like uh no
it's not just you because I've been
hearing weird [ __ ] too and then he drops
the bombshell that he's like I've also
seen some [ __ ] in particular uh what
appears to be the spirit of an
eight-year-old boy named Joseph
now Morgan asks well how do you know
this kid's name and Bob says well the
ghost told me he's I've seen him a
couple of times and he talks to me so
you know I uh tried to make a drink out
of that spiced rum and um
the pineapple juice and it tastes like
[ __ ] I had to poured out
spice room and pineapple juice didn't
taste good why not unless that it tasted
like maybe the pineapple just went bad
that pineapple juice isn't that old is
it no I don't know but it just tasted
[ __ ] terrible I poured it out and got
moonshine instead that's right I forgot
we still had money yeah apple pie
moonshine my sister told me I was
talking to her on Thunder Mountain
Railroad yesterday and we were talking
about that moonshine and she said that
that old smokey because she was in
Tennessee and she went and to a store
that had like a bunch of those she said
they have another flavor yeah that's
really really good but I can't remember
what it is now one peach huh no it was
um I think it was like a coffee flavor
coffee chocolate or espresso shot or
something like that like it sounded
delicious okay and because I told her
about the butter pecan and she's like oh
I didn't know they had butter pecan she
was like I got she's like I saw that we
got the apple pie one so she's had that
um oh that's good but yeah she's just
straight I think she said it was like
coffee chocolate or mocha or something
like that yeah here taste that just
straight
yeah that's delicious it's great yeah
manga says spiced rum with ginger ale is
great yeah I think I'm just having
spiced rum on the Rocks yeah well we
maybe could get some ginger ale because
I like drinking ginger ale just by
itself you know
um all right so so yeah so Bob says yeah
this little ghost boy he's eight his
name is Joseph and he talks to me all
the time which all right now Morgan
doesn't really believe him at first
um she thinks maybe he's just dreaming
it or something because he misses his
actual kids I think what she said on
there she's like well I don't really
want to say that I thought that he was
like Conjuring up an imaginary friend
because you know he felt so bad about
not being able to see his actual kid but
you know
that's kind of the the direction she was
taking it now Bob says he's never
experienced anything like this before
and says it wasn't scary or anything
he's like I just mostly felt sorry for
the kid now Morgan starts to wonder
about like the lock thing and the
footsteps they've been hearing in the
apartment she's like maybe this place is
[ __ ] haunted after all
now Bob happens to have like I said he's
a Wiccan so he has like candles just all
over the place and he has like a candle
for every occasion
um and he has this one like super duper
extra special wicking candle which is a
big honking green one and uh it's
supposed to bring peace to the home and
unify everyone in it like living people
and dead people now so he does that like
he lights this candle initially with no
problem this becomes a point of
contention later on
now uh the next morning Bob has a
doctor's appointment and says he's not
going to be at work until later uh so he
kind of they have a little thing that
has their keys hanging on it or whatever
so he takes his keys and takes off now
Morgan's getting ready to go to work and
she said her keys are on the hook where
they always are but then she looks down
like at her phone or some [ __ ] like that
and then she looks up again to get the
keys and they're not there like they
disappeared like in a second
so then she looks down again and start
was like what the [ __ ] and like did I
put him in here without thinking about
it like starts hunting for him in her
purse but then she turns around and the
keys are back again now she says I know
that when I looked before those keys
were not there and then I looked again a
second later and then they were back
again so you know uh on the show they
show the ghost boy in the background
again like I guess they're kind of like
implying that he stole the keys like he
and then like put him back but she
didn't say she saw that because this is
kind of weak and I realized that oh last
time I was out on the show I just put
ice directly in there
in that [ __ ] moonshine jar was
drinking out and put it back in the
refrigerator
oh yeah so that's ice oh okay the rest
of it in there
laughs
I don't know what he's doing I don't
know what he's doing but yeah so they
showed the ghost but like I said she
didn't say she saw that she just said
that the keys disappeared now uh while
she's at work Morgan is kind of starting
to get a little bit wigged out so she
calls Stephanie she's like yeah I need
to talk to you about some [ __ ]
um and Stephanie says yeah come by here
after work and uh she says you sound
kind of weird like what's the matter and
she's like um
she's basically like well Bob is seeing
a ghost and there's like weird [ __ ]
going on in the apartment and she's like
she knows that Stephanie is a believer
in the Paranormal so we'll actually
listen to her and maybe like have some
solutions or something like that now
Court meanwhile
uh here's the another Well actually
[ __ ] and this guy is actually on
there because I guess at least at the
time that this will actually what the
[ __ ] he is that's what I call you guys
know what I mean you guys know everybody
knows somebody like that so
um the guy that the real Court he's
actually on the show because when this
show was filmed I don't know about now
but Morgan in court were still dating
you know what I mean it had been like
four years let me tell you something
about [ __ ] this situation here
this is one of the rare cases where the
real Morgan is actually a lot cuter than
the [ __ ] actress Morgan she's a goth
girl kind of her goth type reddish kind
of reddish hair
but uh this is kind of funny it it would
that that that wasn't really a good
match between those two yeah yeah this
one they didn't really get um and I mean
the guy that's playing Court yeah
doesn't look anything like the real guy
like the real guy looks a little bit
like a little bit chubby and he has kind
of like long yeah kind of curly hair and
like kind of like a short chin with like
a cleft in it yeah and the guy they have
playing him in the show looks like he's
like Legolas you know what I mean yeah
he looks like a Chad yeah yeah like he's
got like or he looked like not not
and it's not like not Legolas but um
[ __ ] man who does he look like he looks
like some actor that's just a chat yeah
he looks like a Chad like with the
blonde hair and like the chiseled Jaw
and everything like yeah and the real
the real girl is kind of like one she'd
be like one of the top level girls at a
golf club
you know like one of the popular girls
be like that
yeah and like I said she's still around
like her website is still around and
everything like that yeah it's like I
said she's written a couple books she
looked like a goth girl who's trying to
hide the fact that she was goth on
television is she got that as [ __ ] not
really although there is a picture of
her like on her Amazon uh author page
yeah where she looks more she has kind
of like a black like pixie haircut it
looks almost like Tinkerbell but it's
like but it's jet black and it's kind of
like combed and I don't know how old
that picture is because I'm assuming
she's like way older at this although
they said she was 20 in
2003
so
however I should be 43 now yeah so yeah
so that's still fairly young yeah that's
still really young she could still be
going to the club
well yeah we do like us
yeah that's right
but yeah so here's court now this I'm
not really sure I get I don't know but
this kind of weirded me out because
court is actually her supervisor at work
so I know different companies have
different this is Canada maybe they have
different laws but there's a law against
it really like about you know uh you
know supervisor dating but yeah it's
usually policy because well and you can
understand why they don't want like all
kinds of [ __ ] drama and favoritism
and [ __ ] like that but apparently there
are no issues here because court is her
supervisor and he's all Mr Smooth and
asks her out on a date like out for
drinks now she says oh I just made plans
to go to Stephanie's house but I'll take
a rain check on that because you know
there's sparking and there's all kind of
stuff going on there now a court asks
where Bob is because Bob hasn't shown up
at work yet and Morgan is like well he
had a doctor's appointment this morning
but I don't know why the [ __ ] he's not
here because he was supposed to come in
this afternoon
so later on Morgan goes to Stephanie's
house and tells her all about what's
been going on you know vis-a-vis like
all the supernatural Shenanigans now
Stephanie said this kind of like made me
laugh the way that they kind of put this
in Stephanie said you know I was
watching a TV show earlier today that
had Lorraine Warren on it
um and she's like oh and I taped it like
I happened to tape it sit down right
here we could watch it so they show uh
she shows Morgan like the actual clip of
Lorraine and basically all it is is like
a clip of Lorraine saying you know
Spirits are attracted to DAR auras and
blah blah and they know what our auras
is that's what our real real selves are
like yada yada
um Jack says his sister looks she he
Googled Morgan and he says oh my gosh
you look exactly like like my sister
you got a cute sisters there
that's really funny I thought yeah I
thought she was like she was cute she's
so cute she's so cute like I said you
can you can look her now nowadays
because she still has a site
the site and they talked about it on
here and I was curious to see if it was
still around it
so
um
okay so where was I yeah so uh Morgan
finds she's like hey I wonder if this
Lorraine Warren lady could help us out
and sends her an email uh so she says
subsequently like her and Stephanie
became admirers of Lorraine's cases and
investigative methods that's what they
said
so so Morgan gets home when Morgan gets
home from work she finds Bob trying to
light that big green candle remember how
I said before and it lit the first time
but now he cannot get it to light like
it will not like he's been standing
there like all this time he's like
holding it he's like why would a [ __ ]
light and she's like well maybe the
Wick's just wet or something like that
like calm down and he gets like really
cranky about it uh but it turns out that
he's not cranky all you know just
because of the candle also he's like oh
by the way
um I was diagnosed with cancer yeah look
at Hima yeah I think it was leukemia
well they said yeah they said blood
cancer which on the same time
um and he and that's why he never showed
up to work even though he was supposed
to come back in the afternoon now so
Morgan obviously is like freaking out
like oh my God oh my God and he's just
like [ __ ] you talk about it and he gets
like really really uh aggro about it
um so he goes in his room and closes the
door it's like you know leave me alone
like you know he gets all like that
um so then like at least on the show
Morgan and supposedly sees like a black
shadow figure type situation like
walking across the living room in front
of the mirror what whatever but I don't
know if she really saw that because she
didn't say anything like that
so Morgan and court go out on their date
and she's telling him about all the
weird [ __ ] that's been going on
including like all the weird [ __ ] about
the candles now court is being a real
douche about all of this
um pretty much insisting that it's like
I'm I'm gonna prove to you that there's
a scientific explanation for everything
that's going on and I will I'm gonna bet
you money that I'll go back to your
apartment and get that candle to light
and he's like I said he's being a real
well actually [ __ ] about it so
they go back to the apartment and he
lights all the candles like being really
condescending he's like one two and
she's like yeah cool [ __ ] but
those weren't the candles that we were
having an issue with it's that one that
won't light so he lights all the other
ones and then he tries to light that one
and it won't and he's just like oh huh
okay my douchery didn't work on this so
I guess not but then like it suddenly
like Sparks up she said it looked like a
sparkler like it was like like all these
[ __ ] [ __ ] came out of it
um and she said this wasn't like it was
just a regular candle so it probably
shouldn't have done that
so you know what I mean so uh so they're
out there doing that and then Bob comes
out of the room and just like looks at
him like all spookily like whatever and
then kind of like wanders back into his
room and uh Court's like what the [ __ ]
is his deal and I guess that Morgan
didn't want to tell me it's like hey he
has cancer because it's not really her
place to say I guess so she's like um
he's working through some issues right
now so you know Court then leaves
because you know everything's gotten
really awkward
so Morgan's been trying to talk to Bob
but he never wants to talk to her he
just spends all his time cooped up in
his room and he's supposedly talking to
that ghost boy in there like you can
hear him talking to the kid like through
the wall
the next morning though says Morgan Bob
seemed much better like he almost seemed
like back to normal again like he was
all dressed and groomed like regular he
had made coffee whole nine yards he was
you know oh I'm sorry I was being such a
dick blah blah blah uh he's apparently
also made plans to go visit his sons in
Saskatchewan like for the upcoming
weekend
um but despite this like the show still
makes it plain that something is going
on with him because like he's like yeah
bye and then like goes out of the
apartment then he's like you know what I
mean so it's kind of like that kind of
situation they're trying to show you
that like something's still going on
with him
so at this point Morgan goes to take a
shower now on the program they show the
bathroom door like opening by itself and
Morgan here in something weird like a
sigh or a screamy kind of weird noise or
shuffling or whatever and then there's
like Shadows of hands and they like drag
themselves down the shower curtain like
like that
um actual Morgan said I didn't know if
it was going to attack me all I know is
that it want to be very scared something
more than a child was in the house so
supposedly I don't know if that's
exactly how it happened but she's trying
to say that this was like the point at
which she realized that this wasn't like
a little kid or if he was like the
little kid was a real [ __ ]
can be [ __ ] too
um so at work Morgan like basically that
like that happened and she like freaks
out so she goes to work and Bob's like
on the phone because they do like a
computer tech so she's talking to
somebody going yeah you need to fix your
computer and yada yada and she just like
runs up to him and is like Bob Bob
there's like this crazy [ __ ] happened in
the shower and she's like trying to tell
me he's like [ __ ] like chill out like
I'm on the you know with a customer or
whatever
um she's like Joseph was trying to
threaten me and then he gets like really
really butt hurt
um you can't possibly think that Joseph
would mean you any harm like he would
never do anything like that he's just a
little kid
so all of that's going on and Court this
is in a workplace uh you understand so
Court hears the whole conversation and
goes up to Morgan and says you need to
calm down I'm like oh my God don't ever
tell a woman to calm down when she's
like get on set about that because
that's just gonna make her matter so um
so the real Court
what's your name again Morgan what
Morgan Knudsen
k-n-u-d-s-e-n I want to see the site
they're they're talking about her site
yeah yeah
okay so yeah this kind of made me laugh
too like when we were watching the show
so the real court is on there and he is
helpfully explaining because I guess
when she was talking about the weird
[ __ ] that happened when she was in the
shower like with the shower curtain like
coming in and blah blah blah so the real
court on the show like then very very
helpfully explains for all of us you
know stupid women out in the audience
like how temperature differentials and
updrafts work uh yeah well if it's hot
in the bathroom and then like somebody
opens the door and it's a cool draft
like yeah it'll make the curtain blow in
I'm like really gosh thank you for
explaining that to everybody but yeah so
I just thought that was like super funny
like I said he's just like such a well
actually [ __ ] then he says to
Morgan he's like why are you so invested
in this like Paranormal [ __ ] and
then she finally after all this time
like admits oh it's because this has
happened to me before and at this point
we find out that that the whole prologue
with the little girl like going down the
hall and the bright light and all that
kind of stuff was her when she was a kid
like 10 years ago
yeah okay I'm looking at it she's yeah
she's cute she she's older now she kind
of yeah that's a goth girl she's doing
because look she's doing almost like a
Peter Murphy [ __ ] 20. yeah that's the
picture and then she's got she's got
kinda uh what do you call it steampunk
type stuff
yeah that's a scene girl yeah yeah she's
cute she changed well
in the show she's a lot younger she's
with red hair
but I could tell I could spot a goth
come on
Jenny and I are [ __ ] came up in the
scene yeah spotter we could spot him
that's her she's just keeping it
Undercover
which like I said nowadays you don't
really need to anymore right I remember
but I remember when you did have to like
especially if you're trying to keep her
credibility I guess yeah
uh but yeah
so uh so yeah so we find out that the
whole like prologue at the beginning
with the little girl was actually her
which like I said I don't know like what
because like I said I don't know her and
I don't know because it seemed like they
were trying to paint it at first like
when Bob first started talking about The
Ghost and everything like she was
talking about oh I was really a skeptic
skeptic about this kind of stuff but
then she admits later on that like no
some weird paranormal [ __ ] happened to
me when I was a kid so I would have
thought that she would have been more
open to it I don't know maybe that was
just like the narrative that the show
was kind of
trying to put across so um so yeah she's
like yeah it happened to me when I was a
kid now she said
what she described was not exactly like
what they showed like because I feel
like in the prologue they showed like
the the door opening and it was just
like a bright light like you know like
in Poltergeist when the [ __ ] closet
opens and sucks in Caroline or whatever
it but she said
uh what she saw was a white transparent
opaque form she called it a form so I'm
guessing it was like a white like a
person like a like a human kind of form
not so much a bright light I don't know
uh but that's what she said anyway now
uh so Court not real court but the actor
I don't know if he really said like
anything like this to her in real life
um he says those are just nightmares
little girls have nightmares all the
time ooh not little boys no not adults
only little girls have nightmares and I
was like oh my God I would have punched
you in the dick so hard but yeah that
was the actor said that I don't know I
was like okay okay bud
um and she gets mad I mean obviously
understandably and she's like you know
what just forget it
um and she was on the the actual her was
like on the show saying it's like yeah
he was being like uh really unsupportive
I was like yeah clearly
so she goes to talk to Stephanie again
and Stephanie says uh you know I've been
reading all these books you've been
doing like all the Van Helsing research
or whatever and she says we should spend
the night in your apartment and try to
prove that Joseph is really there if
indeed that's what this is using EVPs
and in these earlier shows they always
had to like explain what EVPs were
because I guess that hadn't like
saturated into the culture at large at
that point so they're like you know
electronic voice phenomena we're like
yeah we all know what that is now
um so they're in so they get like uh
because I guess because Morgan was a
musician and she had like this little
tape recorder deal so they're like we're
just gonna use that so they're in
Morgan's bedroom talking about how we're
gonna how they're gonna do this and then
they hear the sound of something
breaking like out in the living room so
they go out there and they find that
Morgan have this kind of like ceramic
dragon that she's been keeping on I
think she said she made it but I'm not
really sure but it was like um it was
like really like uh like had a lot of
sentimental value for her and so it was
on the mantle but now it's like on the
in the middle of the floor and it's like
broken into a million pieces
so she said and nothing else had fallen
off so she said well she considered that
the spirit like declaring a challenge
you know what I mean like he was trying
to like [ __ ] with her specifically
so they do the EVP thing but she says
nothing came out on tape like they
didn't get [ __ ] all so they go to bed
Stephanie hadn't really wanted to stay
overnight but by the time they got done
with what they were doing it was too
late to call the neighbor because like I
said remember somebody had to carry her
up and down the stairs like in her
wheelchair because there was no elevator
so um it was too late the neighbor had
already gone to bed and they're like
she's like okay well you'll have to stay
here then and she's like not super happy
about it so in the middle of the night
they both hear somebody moving around in
the apartment now Bob's not home because
he was out of town
so at first they think it's Bob like
back early from the trip but then the
bedroom door like what Zach was talking
about earlier the bedroom door like
started open but opens by itself and
then slams and opens by itself and then
slams and it keeps doing this and the
thing about it is that Stephanie because
they kind of like got her into the bed
but you know she can't move her lower
half so it's like she can't really you
know uh you know Morgan can't really
like move her around all that good so
she's like laying with her back to the
door so she can't really see what's
going on she just hears a bunch of noise
and she's like what the [ __ ] is going on
back there you know what I mean so it's
that kind of [ __ ] so the door apparently
kept open closing opening and closing
like all night she said Morgan said it
did that from 1 35 in the morning till
six in the morning like it just kept
doing that like all night long and they
were just like freaking it out and she's
like they were essentially like stuck in
this room because you know Morgan
couldn't get Stephanie out of bed by
herself and she didn't want to leave her
there alone obviously so there wasn't
really anything they could do other than
just kind of like lay there and listen
to the [ __ ] door slamming all night
so they tried to call court but there's
no answer because I'm assuming it's the
middle of the night and he's probably
sleeping
so at dawn they finally get hold of
Court he comes over and helps get
Stephanie out the bed into her chair and
back home
court is starting to think that maybe
like maybe I think he's kind of finally
starting to believe her at this point I
guess because Stephanie was there too
and she's like [ __ ] like all
this stuff is happening so
um so he starts to think well maybe you
would be safer someplace else like do
you have someplace else you can stay
um but Morgan's like you know this is my
apartment it's like I don't really want
to have to like leave just because
there's a [ __ ] ghost in there that's
being a douche so they get back to the
apartment and Bob is there now he seems
okay at first and he says while he was
on his trip he bought this other super
duper even more super duper blessed
candle that should be able to light the
green one that they were having so much
trouble lading previously
so while Bob does this Morgan
surreptitiously turns on the tape
recorder to see if she can get some EVPs
because she heard something about like
temperature or something like that I
don't remember what it was
so the green candle lights seemingly
without incident he's like look we
figured it out
um so oh Court also notes Here the real
Court uh notes here that Bob that he had
noticed that Bob's personality had
changed significantly like since he had
moved into this apartment like um his
words where he called him eerie and odd
that's what he called him and that
wasn't what he was like before us but uh
apparently
now when Morgan and Court listen to the
EVP tape back like of when the um the
candle got lit they said as the candle
is being lit there's something that
sounds like a scream which obviously
they didn't hear when that happened in
real life it just came out on the tape
so at this point Morgan calls Lorraine
Warren back
now Lorraine Warren like I said she
didn't come out to this maybe this was
past the point where she was like
traveling to places she's just like
calling places and like yeah sorts
whatever
um so basically Lorraine says yeah it's
a demon
um because that's what she says you
don't have to call her no that's right
that's what she's gonna say she says
Jason Joseph is not a little ghost of a
little boy it's a demon pretending that
it's a little boy like to get to Bob
because
um the ghost or the demon knows that
that's what he would respond to because
he has sons and he misses them and blah
blah blah
um so she's like yeah Bob's possessed um
and he was like at a real vulnerable
place in his life with the divorce and
the cancer and all of that now Lorraine
says what you have to do is you have to
talk Bob into renouncing Joseph also
tells Morgan you need to fortify
yourself with vitamins minerals and
Jesus and so um with Jesus yeah okay she
even I think she even said well I think
that's why I wrote it down funny in my
notes because she used the word fortify
which also made yeah which makes me
think of breakfast cereal yeah so now
it's more Jesus
Frosted Flakes Jesus flakes so uh so
yeah now uh at this point Court tries to
convince Morgan hey you should come
crash at my place but Morgan's like look
I can't leave Bob alone like he needs
help obviously
um and no one else will help him even
though he's still acting uh creepy as
[ __ ]
so Morgan finds him in his room and he's
sitting like in a circle of candles and
she's like hey we need to call a priest
or you need to go talk to a priest and
he's like no I'm not [ __ ] doing that
and gets like really pissed off
um and she says you're different man
kind of thing and um he's like yeah well
a cancer diagnosis will do that blah
blah blah which yeah okay I get that
she's like you know that's not it um and
then she says I bet your sons noticed it
too and then he gets really mad uh he's
just like if I do it well you just shut
up he gets all like [ __ ] pissed off
about it
so Morgan takes Bob to a church but he
pulls a Damien from Omen like when
they're pulling up for the wedding and
he's just like no he doesn't like
overreact like that but he's just like
nope I'm not going in there nope nope
nope and he just like walks away from
the church uh so Morgan meets with this
Catholic priest who is not appearing on
this program and tells her to put a
bunch of like religious paraphernalia in
the apartment and to in particular to
recite the Saint Benedict prayer for the
poisoned and I was like wow that's
really a thing and they make little
cards and everything at least like what
they showed in the thing that's a very
specific
but I guess they that's what they call
it because you're poisoned by a demon or
whatever so that's what you're gonna do
uh priest says wish I could do more but
I'm too lazy to come out to your house
no that's not what he said um he's like
I could do more if Bob would meet would
come here and meet with me like I said
he's too lazy to come out there uh but
again Bob says no I'm not talking to no
priest he also gets really shitty about
all the crosses oh are you a Jesus Freak
now he says and then like yells at her
like take all this stuff down that's the
demon talking
uh but then like while that's going on
he seems to kind of like break down and
like then it's him again for a second
and he kind of starts crying and he's
like I know this isn't me and blah blah
blah I have all this anger and I don't
know where it's coming from
um but then the demon like takes him
back over and he starts getting all
aggro again and screaming and whatnot
now at this point Morgan goes into the
kitchen and then the dishes all like
start rattling like in the in the
cupboards and the shelves and stuff and
then one of them flies her flies off and
like hits her like bam like right in the
forehead like that and leaves like a big
gash I don't know what happened in real
life but that's uh what happens she had
like had a big Band-Aid on her forehead
uh at this point she's like yeah this
[ __ ] this and uh she goes and stays with
court now so she's gonna move in with
him permanently but before she does that
she wants to make one last attempt at
helping Bob so her in court go to the
apartment and start reading that Saint
Benedict prayer like for the poison and
they're just like reading it reading it
I don't know what happened in real life
but on the show uh all they they had
these candles on the table they start
rattling around and then they start
hearing weird noises like screaming kind
of [ __ ] then the curtains start blowing
there's like a whole Phantom wind
situation like I said probably in real
life they were just like sitting there
reading off the card and nothing was
happening but whatever it was like it
freaked both the mount chords like with
chords like we're getting the [ __ ] out
of here and they flee because they
actually bang on Bob's door and try to
get him to come with them but um Bob
says Nah and then apparently what they
show on the show he goes with the Joseph
demon like Joseph comes to the window
he's like hey I'm really a little boy
come and boom run he's just like okay
I'm coming yeah that was that so Morgan
goes back to the apartment has to go
back to the apartment to get her stuff
because like I said she's moving in with
court right
um now she waits until she knows Bob is
at work like they all work together
right so she waits until Court until
Court like called her and says okay he's
here now like you can go back to the
apartment and get your [ __ ]
um because she doesn't know like how
he's gonna react because he's been
acting like really [ __ ] crazy
so while she's at the apartment though
Bob finds out that Morgan took the day
off for personal business and he like
pretty much Twigs on he's like oh that
[ __ ] must be back at the apartment like
getting her stuff so he like ducks out
of work and then goes back to the
apartment to like see what she's doing
um so uh Court tries to actually call
and warn her but she left her phone in
her car and it's like too late anyway
because he'd already been gone an hour
by the time he realized it so Bob comes
back he accuses her of like sneaking
around all this other [ __ ] and she's
like look man like I just try to help
you and I just can't do it anymore like
the your shit's throwing dishes at my
head and I don't like it
um so well you know your [ __ ] is
throwing dishes
well I mean I just use the word [ __ ]
it's just like that's funny like it's
like a thing I know it's like of course
you did it in the American style yeah
and he's stuck yeah your [ __ ] is doing
my [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] your stuff is
[ __ ] with my stuff yeah pretty much
it's gonna have those [ __ ]
[ __ ] red [ __ ] American subtitles
for you people up in Europe to know what
we're talking about although I'm sure
americanisms have seeped their way into
the [ __ ] world globally well yeah
because everybody watches like America
yeah so
so everybody kind of know well but well
not always because it's funny how like
sometimes little things that kind of
slip between the cracks well because
like I said one guy I really like on
YouTube uh his name is Lawrence and he
does a he has a thing called Lost in the
pond and he's British but he's lived in
the US for a really long time and he's
married to an American woman but he's
like even now even though he's lived in
the U.S like in the Midwest for like 14
years or something it's like every now
and then he still comes across like
weird little like turns of phrase and
like weird little names for things that
are strange that like because it's you
know the big stuff that everybody knows
but there's always like little things
that you don't think of and you're just
like why the [ __ ] do you call it that I
don't know when I was going to high
school in Brazil I was in a
um it was a International Private School
and um
curriculum was IB International
Baccalaureate and it was English
speaking
and you had people from all over the
world
Sao Paulo Brazil
had Japanese girls and everything not
boys but girls okay the boys were too
important they had to stay back in Japan
and get a real education all right that
was the thinking
but I'm hanging out with Europeans I was
hanging out with some with a Dutch a
Dutch chick named Manon
and and her brother
and we went to go see a [ __ ] movie
it's the first time we saw a predator
one her and her brother were with me
they just arrived to Brazil and they
were tripping out not only in Brazil but
on me because
English you know Americans you know
and that was one that really blew their
mind I said this is crazy and [ __ ]
they're like what and [ __ ] and [ __ ] and
the whole me ending the sentence with
and [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy you know the
whole [ __ ] thing really it's all means
stuff
but they were laughing like I didn't
know what I was talking about yeah yeah
I'm trying to I'm trying to explain it
and so forth and so forth they thought
it was just me
then it was just not everybody but a lot
of people do that but yeah well a lot of
people do that yeah yeah but because
they learned their English [ __ ] back
in well yeah I mean well that's the
thing it's like learning English and
living somewhere right yeah with where
you grow up speaking English it's two
different things it's just like you know
when I learned French in school if I
went to France they would probably just
like laugh at me because I'm learning
like proper French and they don't speak
they don't talk like that back in those
days when it came to Europeans
the
okay well I hung out with some British
guys too but they went to a British
didn't even go to the same school as us
they went to a British school it was
Catholic it was called I think St Mary's
St Mary's Academy
and the British were on their own
[ __ ] compounds they didn't mix with
any other people and they were a lot
like Americans but they were kind of
like Yankees they were kind of like
somebody from new from the New England
area
they were afraid to mix with Brazilians
and [ __ ] was weird like Japanese they
were like the same way that the closest
Europeans back in those days
that could hang with Americans and
Brazilians inside of Brazil were Swedish
guys not the girls but the guys
the girls were [ __ ] stick in the
booty [ __ ]
stuck up [ __ ]
even Swedish dudes wouldn't date him
they dated Brazilian girls but Swedish
dudes could take even as teenagers could
[ __ ] drink you under the table they
were [ __ ] party animals I liked
Swedish dudes
uh not girls not Swedish girls but you
know that's just little anecdotes from
back in the 80s growing up in the
international expat community in Brazil
it was a trip
yeah I don't know how much of that still
applies nowadays it may not apply today
but back in the day back in the day
[ __ ]
Swedish dudes were kind of like
I wouldn't call them rednecks
they were like Mountain fools
yeah
and all of this start is isn't it
interesting that all I did all I did was
say the phrase your [ __ ] through dishes
at my head yeah and suddenly we ended up
talking to you about Swedish dudes that
are mountain four they're like Mountain
fools they were [ __ ] fun man they
were really [ __ ] within like five
minutes it's mystifying yeah but I was
always good I was only always under the
impression that they thought they were
getting away with a lot of [ __ ] you know
which they probably were yeah because
we'd go out and party and they were
doing all kinds of [ __ ] they could
probably never get away with in Sweden
I was thinking to myself I mean I don't
um it doesn't usually occur to me that I
swear a lot because I'm just like kind
of used to that's how I talk yeah
um I kind of became aware of it like
yesterday because me and my sister were
at Disney and I was like maybe I
shouldn't swear so like I you know I got
self-conscious about acceptance you know
it's Disney so there's like millions of
kids everywhere and then I found that I
couldn't really stop myself yeah because
I was like that's just how I talk so I
tried not to like talk too loud when we
were in uh when we were in line or
anything like that because you know how
I do
but yeah uh so where was I so I was
almost done okay so uh like I said so
she's at the apartment trying to get her
[ __ ] Bob's like you're sneaking around
she's like look man I try to help you um
and I'm not doing this [ __ ] anymore it's
like not worth it and she's like look
Joseph isn't a little boy it's a demon
like you know it's not a little boy that
needs you and then Bob freaks out and
says the other way around I'm the one
who needs Joseph and then screams her to
get the hell out
so she then turns around and apparently
like on the show they show him like
showing that she saw the ghost boy now I
think maybe she did see this because
um she apparently sees the ghost boy and
hears him saying some stuff I couldn't
tell what it was he was saying uh
because like I said the I couldn't get
the closed caption to come on but then
she said she saw what the thing really
looked like now she did say she
described it and this is like the real
lady she said
it looked completely inhuman she had
black eyes thick gray skin Twisted limbs
those were the words that she used
so she's like implying that she saw this
the actual thing and obviously it didn't
look like a cute little kid so after she
sees that she's like yep I made the
right decision and then gets the [ __ ]
out of Dodge thank you very much Aaron
have we already discussed Tom's mustache
briefly briefly we have
he's decided he's decided that he's
going all in on it
I like it like I said I didn't think I
would I'm not usually a fan of facial
hair but some people can wear it and
some people can't you know what I mean
um and I wasn't sure because I'd never
seen him with facial hair before because
he's never had it and I was just kind of
like I don't know like I'm trying to
imagine it I can't imagine it but now
that he's kind of got it on there I was
like no I think I kind of like it I kind
of like it but we'll see he's gonna let
it grow outside and see like what it
looks like I just think the same thing
like my brother grew like a bearded
mustache and I was like I didn't know if
I'd like that either but I was like you
know what it looks good on you I got it
I kind of like it I kind of like it so
it depends on the person's face I guess
um so yeah so you weren't uh uh I
thanked Aaron for the for the Super Chat
and said have we already discussed Tom's
mustache yeah that was a long time ago I
said yeah we already talked about that
[ __ ] massive massive [ __ ] sexual
impact
overpower the audience
that [ __ ] [ __ ] Norse [ __ ]
dramatic
Golic [ __ ]
Celtic [ __ ] manhood known as the
[ __ ] Warrior beard the Fu Manchu the
evil spotness
but no we're gonna see how it goes I'm
either Gonna Keep just this
or I'm gonna keep a sides we're gonna
see how it goes he's either gonna do the
evil Spock or I might just do evil Spock
all right we're gonna see what we'll see
what's easiest to live with
what looks the best
Zach says haha I just Googled Mountain
fools and it brought up a Norwegian
comedy movie called fools in the
mountain yeah so they know what you're
talking about of course I'm not an idiot
I'm no bumpkin
Swedish Boys in Brazil I mean Sweden
Norway they're two different countries
but they're the Swedish boys in the late
80s in Brazil in an International High
School
were Mountain fools okay they were
[ __ ] Mountain fools
they drank
they chased Brazilian girls
they tried to spend all their dad's
money
um
they would speak a mixture of [ __ ]
Swedish and English and they were
English yeah yeah yeah they speak
English and Swedish in the same sentence
it was [ __ ] funny thank you again
Aaron oh and birthday present thank you
so much that's so nice of you that's it
thank you this has been like a really
really good birthday well it's it's been
an extended birthday because like I said
my sister took me to Disney yesterday
for my birthday
just a little refresher course on the
it's good
I told my yeah my sister said they made
another I think she said it was coughed
like chocolate coffee or coffee or
something coffee it's butter pecan
moonshine yeah
because I told her I was like man they
had the apple pie and the butter pecan
at ABC but I didn't see the coffee one
yeah maybe you'd have to like order it
I'm not really sure miss Lee all the way
up in Korea
you gotta Google what butter pecan is
it's a southern
dessert man speaking of pecan I still
got birthdays
I think I still got half that damn cake
left half that birthday cake in there
it's in the freezer this is butter pecan
moonshine yeah and moonshine is a
powerful
Southern Homemade
aphrodisiac yeah
it's not not quite
thank you Sly it's alcohol nearly pure
alcohol and moonshine
some people just call it Shine all right
it's stronger than vodka not quite as
strong as Everclear it's not pure
alcohol but it's getting there
but you make a you put it in a damn
butter pecan flavor it's all creamy
like melted ice cream it's beautiful
Danny Rowling said the 2009 vampire film
let me in would be a stick review I kind
of like a slide thank you I liked let me
in but I liked the original uh
uh movie better Let the Right One In but
that man was good too that was the
American version uh all right so let me
just like there's like literally like
two more paragraphs
so I don't think you were here but she
said that she saw the ghost boy but then
she saw what it really looked like so
she saw its demonic form yeah I'm
guessing who's she the on the show oh
yeah yeah I know Morgan okay so that's
where we're at now yeah yeah yeah
um so she said and like I said she
described it as completely inhuman black
eyes thick gray skin Twisted limbs
that's what you said uh so she got the
[ __ ] out of Dodge after that Bob stopped
showing up at work and moved out of the
apartment leaving no forwarding address
so nobody knows if he's still around did
he die because he had cancer nobody
knows uh whatever happened to Bob lakima
can live a long time I checked yeah
that's what I'm saying so I don't so I
don't know like they don't know if he's
still around they don't know what
happened to him uh so when this show was
uh was taped Morgan and Court were still
together that was four years like after
these incidents and uh then Morgan and
her friend Stephanie also formed a
paranormal investigation team type thing
called entity Seeker which is still
around to this day so Morgan uh Knudsen
if that's how you pronounce your name if
it's not I apologize uh she's actually
she has an Amazon author page she's
actually written two books one of them
is called the gift of instinct
paranormal lessons for an extraordinary
world and one is called teaching the
living from heartbreak to happiness in a
haunted home uh both of them say 2022
but that second one says it's second
edition so there might have been like
another Edition that came out a lot ago
and then she just like reissued them
like this year or whatever all the beard
mustache guys are sending money talking
about sexual impact
well I'm going away from the Roman
soldier look to more the Germanic
barbarian look you know so I'm I'm it's
phases you know it's like it's like it's
like [ __ ] David Bowie
Changes turn and face the strength yeah
you gotta change see change the [ __ ] up
I mean as long as you don't go full ZZ
Top no I'm not gonna go full season
no no if anything man the
what I've always liked is kind of like
the evil Spock yeah the evil spot
mustache
or um
I've always was like a bit because I
because I'm I'm bald
I always like to [ __ ] Ming the
merciless
[ __ ] beard something like that don't
they call that a Van Dyke maybe I've
heard it called you just have like
that's real I don't know and it's kind
of pointed right yeah a little thing
like like the devil like the devil
Satan
[Laughter]
that looks good with a bald head
yeah you look like Anton Lavette oh yeah
I go oh Anton
is that what you're really trying to do
you're trying to look like antelope no
actually this is of course a [ __ ] uh
very common facial hair apparatus it is
in in the motorcycle scene
your facial hair Amber it's a facial
hair apparatus now that's gonna have to
be another shirt that we made yeah put
your little face on it with your little
thing and it's like this is my facial
hair yeah and it's gonna have like all
it'll be like little ladders and like
all kind of like little [ __ ] like
somebody's working on your face sny's
going oh [ __ ] Tom because seeing oh yeah
dude I used to um when I'm warmed up I
used to do whole musicals and [ __ ] when
I was in high school [ __ ] I can sing
well yeah he did all the musical though
[ __ ] I can do [ __ ] Morrissey he
was the theater guy bill yet it was a
theater guy Morrissey [ __ ] Billy Idol
uh I love I love singing um David Bowie
um what else do I say oh Glenn dancing
yeah when I'm really [ __ ] slamming
I'll do Danzig and you'll think you're
listening to a [ __ ] dancing record
of the devil I'm not warmed up but I
could you do a nice uh Roy Orbison Roy
Orbison yeah
blues sound and stuff Elvis I can do
Elvis
maybe not late Elvis I had to really get
warmed up before I can do if I can dream
and all that I'd have to really because
holy [ __ ] that if I can drink and then
like late Elvis he's [ __ ] like
Luciano Pavarotti so I'd really have to
[ __ ] get in condition for that it
takes practice
you got to warm up and do a lot of
practice good practice breath control
and voice control yeah guys singing from
your but I could get into top shape in
two months
I could cut an album it would take me
two months
Danny Rowling said looks like Tom's
drinking his southern style sperm Clinic
specimen go ahead
[ __ ] that's funny man we need to
send him some money send him a Super
Chat that was a good one that was good I
can't send it okay we can't send you I
would send you a ten dollars
was good but I um yeah I [ __ ] you got
me that that was pretty good you got me
he's like ooh now I can't drink it he's
like a hardcore back in the Army we
would just sneak out there and piss in
each other's canteens in the middle of
the night [ __ ] and then they'll call
him out on it is that that does that
taste all right it does I'm pissing that
[ __ ] last night you [ __ ] you pouring
that [ __ ] Cappy
or you're really hardcore says no you
didn't and just keep drinking
well yeah because well honestly it's
much easier to just say you pissed and
then yeah yeah yes I know you did just
keep drinking because I wouldn't believe
you if you said that Sly said uh I like
your blue hair Jenny thank you very much
uh so yeah I mean we pretty much got to
the end of it like I said um she has a
site called entity Seeker she's written
a couple books
um and it looks like her thing is like
still going and she seems to have she's
been on uh Destination America she's
been on um
this is what it says in her bio it says
her she's the resident paranormal expert
featured on haunted hospitals and
paranormal 9-1-1 oh I didn't know about
that okay so she's making a living in
the Paranormal apparently like yeah and
they had there were some pictures on the
website where she was like given a
presentation and there was like a whole
room full of people so I guess like
she's well she does have star power and
she wrote a book and she is cute she's
cute and she's um she still looks good
according to the uh the uh photographs
that I've seen she's about 40 something
and held together
so I applaud it yeah you know so that's
kind of what what her deal was yes kind
of what our deal was and I guess this is
kind of oh Morgan this is kind of like
her uh introduction to the introduction
to the scene I guess although it does
say in her bio that it says she's been
involved in the world Karen oral fanatic
for over 16 years which yeah that tracks
uh her story began with a great great
grandfather who was the president and
founder of the Canadian Association of
cyclical research in 1918. and if you're
watching the show Jenny's done many
books on the Paranormal and if she looks
great if you want to hire her she could
also do [ __ ] presentations we've been
to many [ __ ] um uh uh horror
conventions and stuff and [ __ ] I sell
all her books of course because you get
me to give me a stack of books you're
not going to get away without buying one
he's gonna beat your ass no I'm just
going to go up and start talking
how you doing I love your hair by the
way those shoes are fantastic have you
ever heard of Jenny Ashford never heard
of Jenny I mean let me let me introduce
my girlfriend she's a [ __ ] paranormal
and [ __ ] a true crime author next
thing you know they're sitting there
taking pictures and [ __ ] she's
autographing books and sell them all
but they're great books they're great
books I believe I believe in our product
[Laughter]
yeah I still want to like finish that
novel I started writing but oh you got a
new novel coming up which one was that
it's one I've been working on for a
while like I said it's based on a true
crime case but it's like a fictionalized
like I'm gonna go Supernatural with it
how's it unseen how's unseen um what was
the uh
the uh the True Crime serial killer one
what was it uh you're what three right
yeah I did a Trilogy okay well there
there so there will be no four I'm
thinking about it like the thing about
it because I put up that crime in
Memorial site and I've been and I
started that channel so I'm thinking
because I had written some stuff for
faceless villain for so I'm thinking
about just like doing videos with that I
don't know but I might compile them like
later on either that or just do a new
serial killer compilation and restart it
won't be faceless film it'll be
something separate yeah maybe that too
I don't know I haven't decided Aaron
says Tom sounds like the ShamWow guy
yeah basically he is like this yeah well
okay that's what you kind of honest
you're calling you should have been like
all those like infomercials oh no [ __ ]
that
no not back in those days not back in
those days I think those guys actually
didn't make much money
I think they probably got a couple Grand
to make those commercials and that was
it
yeah Brad never sell it probably never
saw a dime after that
I always wonder about that like
especially the ones that got like really
famous yeah they probably they probably
did that in a day and got paid two grand
and that was it like didn't the ShamWow
guy get in trouble for something or
wasn't it was it [ __ ] that he got in
trouble for like ooh they caught him
smoking pot I'm like hey I don't know
what it is a crap so we're down nowadays
uh yeah so we're done with that so yeah
that was monster in the apartment okay
season four episode 12. uh very fun
episode I actually quite enjoyed this
episode I had totally forget and I had
totally forgotten about it
it's another one of those ones that
I think I got it confused with another
episode
I know what I'm confused with another
episode but I don't know what the other
episode is called that I'm confusing it
with but if I saw it I would know it but
yeah this is actually like a really good
one that I just like forgot about it
because there's so many good ones like
in the first four or five seasons that I
just like keep forgetting them
so um let me go down and make us a pizza
you're gonna go make us yeah Journey uh
anything you got to address there I
don't think so Danny rolling said
subspecies vampire films to make for a
good review yeah I've been wanting to do
this for a while I've I've only seen the
first one but I really do like the first
one I don't know if the other ones are
worth watching but I think um shutter
just added the first subspecies like not
too long ago and maybe the second and
maybe third one but I don't know we'll
see maybe we'll watch that tonight I
remember that being good but we'll see
what we feel like when we get into it so
thanks everybody for dropping by today
thanks for super chats and uh I guess
we'll be back tomorrow talking about
whatever movie we decide to watch
tonight and then Wednesday night we're
gonna do our Maiden show which this week
is going to be about Creepy astronaut
deaths okay like creepy space stuff like
that okay it's not astronauts so yeah so
that should be a fun show creepy ass not
death yeah all right so uh thanks
everybody for dropping by have a good
rest of your evening and we will see you
guys again tomorrow evening
good night